right now you think of a lot of these
internet of everything devices will be
sitting in silos because one
manufacturer builds this thing and
another manufacturer builds this but you
can imagine mashing them together will
be a really interesting thing like my
washing machine actually tells me or my
dryer tells me when the clothes are
dried and shows a notification on my TV
screen so I know not to leave the stuff
in there and let it get wrinkled I mean
that you know what all join is it's a
way of allowing different objects to
pass messages to each other in a very we
tried to simplify it as much as possible
the other thing that we did was we ate
at open source because we don't want
people feeling like this is a Qualcomm
attempt to own that layer what we're
trying to do is just you know raise the
water so that everybody kind of can play
in this area